you spend most employing somewhere yeah
use you spend most of your time in the
movie with Buddy Hackett yes I know and
what a what a tremendous gentleman and
and a a great comic you know what was
that like because you know those of us
who loved buddy you know was there
anything that didn't make the screen
because it wasn't appropriate
well I think that anything you can say
about Buddy Hackett would be appropriate
and John you up okay are you waiting
Oh John this was the cations up this was
your first movie this was my first movie
almost my last not because of the movie
in the gas because because of me I guess
no I I wanted to work standing people
are probably wondering I hope they are
some of them maybe for why why I have
this cowboy hat
that's a why have you got that be right
with you this is why Dean this is why
Dean left Jerry ah
no offense no offense no at a rate I'm
absolutely alone San Li asked me I think
or sit was kidding I didn't know that he
said I'd like to have you for high noon
and I said my god what a part you can
beat the life out of light bridges in a
you know hey now and yeah you can really
can you ride and I said not well but I
can write I'd rather not well you can go
out of town with Grace Kelly and a sulky
so I said God and by the way you pick up
a million two could be on the picture
about three months and I said she says
sure like the million - can you shoot
mm-hmm straight I was in the Marines and
I I wish I was don't get about that
my parents didn't know they thought I'd
run away for the night I was gone three
years so at a rate I said a qualified
expert with Bissell so he said well this
is a 40 to 45 but this is not a you know
Miami so I said I'll call I can shoot so
then I said you know when he puts that
watch because it's called AI noon he
puts that watch in his pocket or he
picks it up looks at it I don't want to
fake
I want a Patty Philippe or or a Rolex he
said hey they're not even going to see
that I'm going to see it so consequently
Gary Cooper got the part he didn't get a
Rolex
but it Jonathan winters who I considered
a force of nature
yeah Jonathan winters Johnny he did by
the way before I ever interviewed Mel
Brooks on the set of of the show I I
interviewed him all the time and he just
never stopped being funny and making
people laugh but what intrigued me about
this man is he sat quietly all day long
while everything was going on and he had
a knife in his hand and he started with
a block of wood of square block of wood
about three pinches by three inches and
he whittled he kept whittling and
whittling and we don't know what he's
what are you whittling he wouldn't say
what he was whittling he just kept
whittling very quietly when nobody was
around he was still whittling by the end
of the he had whittled and this very few
people can do this maybe a chicken can
but he whittled a perfect egg a
beautiful egg out of this hard block of
wood Johnny do you still have that egg
I've laid so many
mine are not wooden anymore